I'm a water quality a water quality
technologist holy [__] this is amazing
50 years ago it would be like what' you
do I cook and I clean and this
is you wouldn't even be
here your hair is fantastic are you like
a hairdresser it looks so neat what's
what's your
vocation an engineer holy [__] [__]
yeah [__] stem girls in stem yeah re
yeah [__] the power what do you what do
you engineer uh I sell commercial you
sell commercial HVAC equipment holy [__]
you saw those forest fires you were like
money yeah wow what's the what's the
highest BTU you go
to come on you got to be quicker with
that 2 million where are you selling 2
million okay you you're very bad at your
job of selling commercial H are you also
in the h track industry what do you do
uh I'm a water quality a water quality
technologist holy [__] this is amazing
50 years ago it would be like what' you
do I cook and I clean and this
is you wouldn't even be
here but now you're selling air
conditioners you're making sure the
water's drinkable where in New York has
the best water quality I'm from Canada
you're from Canada [__] get
get
them they started
this wow holy [__] so where in Canada
has the best water or where do you look
after the water for uh in Manitoba in
Manitoba that's moose isn't it moose
land growing up though surely you didn't
want to do these jobs right this
wasn't I want to be a princess I want to
be a teacher I want to sell HVAC
equipment and not be entirely sure about
the
btu
what did you want to be when you were
little a vet a vet what were your
favorite animals to put
down it's what the job
is it's that's why you didn't do it you
take the first class like all right
welcome to vet school kill this
dog I'd rather just cool it down if
that's
okay you want to be a vet and what did
you want to be a wrer a wrer
oh cool what type of writing like a no
like a novelist oh you got what's your
novel that's inside
you it's gone now oh tragic isn't it
when you see the Hope die in the eyes
now I just work for the man you're
looking over here like these are two you
know like what what do you guys do
Finance Finance [__] yeah bet your
parents are well proud of you
right you don't know about you don't
know about that what did your parents
want you to
do whatever you wanted oh yeah
self-fulfilling um but did you want to
do Finance um a teacher a teacher and
then you were like [__] the kids get the
paper get the bag all right cool and
then my my Ralph Lauren t-shirt wearing
dude has this already been touched upon
they got nice arm show them off you know
what uh what's your what's your
profession uh work at hedge fund you
work at a hedge fund [__] you could
[__] buy me couldn't
you come to my home Dance with Me
Jester right and is that what you wanted
to be when you were little you just like
I just want to be rich yeah kid I when
you were a kid you dreamt about it [__]
yeah [__] get your goals you see it's
you know it's nice to know that you know
women can do whatever jobs they want now
but they still can't get the goals the
way that the lads can well um I I want
to celebrate you guys you know whether
you're doing the job that you wish you
could or the job that you uh didn't
think ever existed so uh B do me a favor
let's let's make up a song for these
guys let's uh let's do this cuz yeah
growing up I wanted to be a rapper and I
couldn't achieve that goal fully so I
became a comedian who uh makes up rats
about people in the front row so let's
uh let's do it this way the [__] is is
this cuz I did jokes about India you're
like yeah whip out the sitar I like it
cool this is
cool [__] know I feel like we should
be doing
[Music]
this
is this a terribly terribly racist thing
to do I no if you've seen a Bollywood
movie that's exactly how the dancing
goes cool
fine with chuckling feeling cringe at
the way that I dance girl on the edge of
the stage saying Finance as a kid my
parents they didn't care said pick your
dreams like stars from the air if you
want to work in finance grab your chance
you can do it and fly by the seat of
your pants make the cash make it funny
yeah you be a legend over here with your
hedge fund best friend he'd be wanting
to get that bag when he was a 5-year-old
he was feeling sad like I got no cash no
pocket money I want to go to a show and
see a guy who's funny and say right
jokes for me and then perform them
throwing all the Franklin there with no
warning the Benjamins stacking it so
high like Scrooge McDuck but a much
younger guy who's so handsome with the
big biceps over to the right maybe I
stepped on a Minefield in a dangerous
area talking to some people it couldn't
be scarier they're from Canada they set
fire to trees and they waed the air down
beneath let me tell you about this you
repositioning you probably got a unit
from your air conditioning blow it to
the South to the east coast burning the
trees like these are toast we need to
make sure Americans choke on the smoke
especially that nerdy Brit bloke while I
rap you are like I do HVAC I can do
engineering with that I don't know the
btu that's the thermal units I said 2
million you really need to improve it
the training that's a Nob braining thing
over here look at the joy that you can
bring you're like yes front row at the
comedy show I do the Canadian H2O make
sure that it's pure you can drink it no
cloudiness no impurities it sinks it
filtering in many different ways that I
show you the water flows purely in
Manitoba what a very good Province the
best you can get but back in the day you
wanted to be a vet you had a Lust For
Life like maybe I can help cats with a
kind of lazy eye I put an eye patch and
then Kitty can see Nine Lives to live go
on Kitty be free but then you realize
basically the cats just die you are like
no reassess my life back into HVAC the
HVAC wanted to be a writer ever so crazy
hopefully you'll achieve it I'm not
being funny but even if you got a best
seller my boy here would still have the
most
[Applause]
[Music]
money hello it's me the guy you just
watch rapping this is a slightly
different video it is my six favorite
wraps from 2023 I hope you enjoy them
please do comment which one you like the
most and if there's a wrap from this
year that you prefer to some of these
let me know cuz I I have no idea really
what people like if you came to a this
year if you liked a video if you shared
a video thank you so much come along to
a show next year if I'm coming near you
put your name on the mailing list in the
comments uh we've got some really
exciting stuff coming up for 2024 we
recorded a weekend of shows in Texas
we're going to be releasing that as a
kind of 40-minute special I've got a
really great show I'm touring at the
moment with a live band very excited
about that and I've got a game out
called rap battles we'll put a link to
that in the comments as well but it's
freestyle rap meets Cards Against
Humanity anyone of any skill level can
play it you can just you know rap battle
your grandma and find out that she's way
better than you from me happy uh 2024
thank you for enjoying 2023 it was an
amazing year a big year got an ear
piercing that was the highlight and um
here from my uh wife's childhood bedroom
thank you so much and uh I'm looking
forward to 2024 enjoy all the RS and let
me know which was your favorite we're
doing a freestyle rap people over here
what would you like a rap
about [__] amazing ventriloquism that
was incredible what was the
suggestion you are actually sat there
what's your voice is pervasive it's like
it's like God is suggesting things
himself did you just say trains yeah yes
I'm so excited for this because the tone
of your voice suggests you are of a
level of autism where you know every
train
possible
I I used to work with autistic kidss my
brother is autistic and so he's very
intelligent if you give him a Rubik's
Cube takes him 12 seconds to say thank
you
and trains I love it trains suggestion
number one I know you're like I know
you're like oh trains is an easy thing
to wrap out don't worry we're going to
make it like monotonous trains it's
going to be good so this section over
here what do you want to wrap
about did you just say is everyone here
stoned
cuz you couldn't hear that in the most
Lana Del re voice ever she was just like
power
Alliance is that what you did are you is
the person whose lap you're sat on did
you come here with him is he holding you
hostage and you being absolutely sedated
are you sure blink if you can to suggest
she's doing this um okay so power lines
great trains power lines so there's some
hands up at the back yeah you're waving
this is great what would you like a wrap
about
Pluto no longer being considered a
planet Pluto no longer being considered
a planet do you do you work in space no
no I work in beverage you work in
beverage I guess you know there's the
food and beverage industry and you're
like yeah [__] the first
half beverage for life okay Pluto no
longer being considered a planet power
lines trains this corner here what would
you like a wrap about cross crosswords
lovely stuff which is your favorite one
to do New York Times New York Times said
as if I'm an idiot for doing anything
else it's the one for the purists
Chris okay cross wordss um and then
there's there's the table right at the
back are just waving enthusiastically
yeah what would you like a w about I I
couldn't hear that Zu MK Zuckerberg vers
musk oh because um yeah because they're
going to fight in in what in JSU fight
cage fight oh [__]
cool great to the death that would be
good winner winner takes all
becomes wow okay musk versus Zuckerberg
power lines trains this is this is going
to be adequate no I don't think I know
obviously we remembered Pluto not being
a planet and
beverages um and then our one from over
here was crosswords okay this is what
we're going to do we're going to do a
freestyle about all those things DJ do
me a favor drop that beat and this is
what I said it's going to be a freestyle
R made up on the spot based entirely on
that do not worry it will not be
anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly toe curling [__] as you
are expecting it to be you seem so
unconvinced we're going in yes I'm
trying to find right from my mind
Electrify at the power lines people
worry giving them stage four cancel at
the 5G you see them more they've got to
Big it up get electric gridge you need
the voltage 11 don't harm the kids in
the UK okay we're slightly more naughty
we don't do 110 or 120 we double 240 I
caught these frazzle on the fingers if
you've got a ladder long enough and you
can bring this Birds perching on I'm
like oh shoot how are these feathery
friends not electrocuted for you you
were slightly sedated guy on your lap
like yes applicated she be there
basically out of her mind then you drop
back to life and you say power lines
with slightly more energy than one dude
there who took one simple breath of air
he inhaled and then he exchanged he says
from his vocal cords trains that's what
I love and I show this I emotive about
the locomotive Stevenson's rocket that's
the first of the kind but now you've got
the Am track with the power lines
overhead it takes a longer time than
playing your car but don't worry You' be
lowering your carbon footprint wouldn't
you think that's worth the cash actually
it's really [__] expensive first
class can't afford that so you flying in
coach lady at the back she be like a
really hope you ram about Pluto there
used to be nine but now only eight
planets they can Define my very simple
method or easy method speeds up naming
what well the P's up 's up they drop it
off I can really see it's so small in
the distance and looks so icy they say
it's not a planet anymore of course they
say it's basically a block of ice a tiny
dwarf you're just rubbing it in it face
what do you think you're a [__] planet
and I work in
H the details where the devil is no need
for food i' be getting beverages i' be
pulling all the Taps i' be serving all
the beer is that what it means you like
this drink's clear and this one's cloudy
so this one's worse clean all your pipes
I'm feeling quite T quite tense why
because I've really observed it's
absurdly hard for me to solve the New
York Times cross word one across name a
planet ah [__] I thought Pluto would fit
I can't stand it five letters well then
what could it be Venus probably you need
the V I'm quite venal I really carry
myself with pride I peel the white boxes
in the black I try and hide and if you
get it wrong just look up online you can
find the cheeks and yes we're going
sometime to have the fun the lady at the
back remind me girl because the mind's
gone slack of course we got it feeling
in raage you've got one angry
billionaire there in the cage is like
hello there I live in San Francisco it's
not his voice but just let it go for
this show Mark B he slings with the hook
he's like I stole the idea for Facebook
from the Winkle boss twins I'm coming
for your Elon a musk has just done lines
of coke he's on some real crazy [__]
he's like f get away he calls in his tag
team partner that's Grimes she comes in
and shrieks at the dude ah Elon and Mark
have you proved he goes and he punches
him and then goes too far and elon's
gone he's just [__] off to Mars and
there the Zuck is left he's like hey I'm
the Victor today in the BJJ cuz that's a
little sport that he picks dude the
nerdy Facebook ler does Brazilian
Jujitsu have any dog owners in the front
room yeah okay so what's your dog called
Roa Roa that's a silly name that ruins
my theory Roa not not Rover Roa Roa
that's red in Spanish it's red in
Spanish I apologize for my innate racism
there for being like what a silly name
but really as a British man I feel like
what else could I have
said is it is it a red setter is it a
red dog of any sort pit a pitbull oh
[__] do you have kids we used to
yeah scary dogs aren't they they're very
sweet it's as you know everyone knows
pit bus are actually good dogs it's only
the owners who make them bad so you got
if youve got a bad dog it's because the
person who has the dog so I'm sure Roo
is very lovely and has never snatched
off a toddler's face
he used to he used to be called Blanco
but then
[Applause]
uh in England we don't learn Spanish but
I I picked that one up
so it was either that or Gringo I think
they both mean the same
thing so Roa Roa the Pitbull that's very
cool um may may I inquire us to your
name yeah Jenna Jenna hey but you have
so you're not but you have a sexy
accent here you're from here I I know
but which
bit oh yeah CU I've never have heard of
it New Hope Pennsylvania that is that's
a real [__] you can tell we got off
the shits we just walked around a bit
and we like New Hope
Pennsylvania and then they went a bit
further and they were like lots of
people shooting us with arrows
Pennsylvania um what uh what did you do
Jen
oh my God it's clearly not as hilarious
as you think it is it's always like oh
my God she works in
HR I'm building a Sci-Fi Universe you're
building a Sci-Fi universe that is
laughable that is laughable well I mean
look I would have expected that of this
gentleman here
you oh what's the theme a it's like you
know if pirates met my haircut
what um look we can't we're not enemies
we got both got the same shoes on
haven't we um I'm going to take these
off now I don't want to be associated
with
your top knotted kind I'm still tall
don't
worry um what please don't steal them
they have custommade
insoles I'm doing well and I over
pronate [__] podiatrist in the back
there so you're building a Sci-Fi
Universe um for uh television or for
books or for video games coms for video
games comics and nfts two years ago
people would have given a big wo at the
end of it and now they're like oh that's
sad that's the big focus on the video
games I reckon and what's the what's the
kind of vibe of the I really feel weird
being barefooted on the stage I don't
like it I don't like it it feels very
Laurel Canyon 1960s what um what tell us
give give us the pressy of it unless
it's an NDA okay uh it's called the
wanders it's called the wanders it's spy
and like kind of retro Spacey and retro
original and not to stamp on anyone's
dreams or anything that's very cool the
wondrous is Spacey retro and psychedelic
J very excited when you were little when
you were little girl growing up in New
Hope Pennsylvania what did you what did
you want to
be don't know you don't know you just
fell into sci-fi World
building are you is it of your own
accord or is this I'm forcing
you produce
me it was I met him at Burning you met
of course you did
you if you hadn't brought it up we all
would have assumed a burning man and
then and then do you facilitate iasa
trips what's your child man an
accountant who on the weekends is like
no I am a
shaman I grow you grow
[Applause]
iasa I mean these like proper people in
the front row and then a den of
equity utter utter filth this is this is
the type of deviance for which I will
not
stand you sci-fi World build and graska
you call your dog by a Spanish name
I mean do you have any tattoos of course
you do what are they triangle a
triangle where is it may I
ask because it grounds it's there
because it grounds
you it's the most structurally sound of
the
shapes any Engineers will know
wow did you did you tell the person
tattooing you that when you had it done
or you just like it's my favorite
shap I'm from
Pennsylvania would you like an
nft wow you met bur this is brilliant
this is this is all we need is it
okay Jen um let's get one final
thing what is uh where was your most
wondrous holiday where did you go for
your most wonderful
holiday like in in the the world not
like internally when you were to the
Amazon you actually went there okay all
right uh DJ do me a favor let's do this
let's um we're going to celebrate Jen in
all her many
forms of which I'm sure there are many
and gentleman with the the beautiful
hair what's your name Emil are you
French Swedish okay that's allowed it's
spelled slightly differently um
okay
don't need to be rude yeah you know we
need this I'm not saying you're an egyp
you're just Swedish you love the meat
balls no fear I make it clear this guy
works at Ikea he shaves the hair at the
Sid top not high spell it meal e m i
with the L not the E like the French
language if you want to go to burning
man yeah he'll [__] manage he can
build you the camp build you the tent he
works out till the week before getting
tense looking so Hench make sure it's
freshly shaved he just found himself
like oh yesterday I'm the Swedish guy
better than the rest you can see me on
Sesame Street like I am the chef saying
H go ABA yo that's what we do but we're
moving on to you the king of all men
like the pirate hair do but we focus on
Jen one thing she's after grow in
Iowaska do it in apartments yeah that's
a disaster of course you can't live in
Manhattan you wouldn't have the square
footage that you need to have it happen
and you go to New Hope Pennsylvania you
a whole farmyard acres and Acres just
feels as far as you can see iasa from
the vine or the tree or the leaves or
however it's made I'm quite as stute I
know you've got to mash it up blend in
the root and this guy he goes down to
the Jungle he says yes we'll make
ourselves humble and grounded we'll go
down understand you all what's this
tattoo it's a triangle it's
aide
two like a pyramid cuz it's got a large
base like a beat that we're playing here
it's got a large base never wasting this
when you go down below you're like oh ho
ho I'm really tripping I know the future
I can see I scratch that I was picturing
nfts and that's down the it didn't go
well but this sci-fi thing holy hell yes
I'm pretty sure I can call it Wanderers
did you say Wanderers or wonders it
doesn't even matter I just keep rapping
when I'm on it take the iasa then I'm
suddenly vomit vomit vomit vomit yes
it's so thrilling tripping off my balls
when I World building oh it's retr
psychedelic of course it is the kids
love it when they see the trip is
rewarding you come back from the Amazon
jungle you back up here see a mil you
like some of all us having fun that's
what we do you're outside there in
nature with you and what you got by your
side your best friend it's Roo he be
there like I in 10 my name's [__] red
it's from Spanish you thought I
Disappeared you thought that I would
vanish but I'll be here yes I'm so
cheerful call me the Pitbull I used to
be white in the face but now I spit all
the toddler one ho no even though when
you were probably the hero that's the
wandering dog for Jen and Emil that's
how he
[Music]
feel sometimes I post these online I'm
like this is be fun this I would be
murdered I would like everyone here to
think of a word or a topic or a phrase
that you'd like a rap about but there's
some there's some wait wait wait did you
just shout
Mexicans I should ask are you a Mexican
yeah I'm a Mexican can you confirm okay
cool because again I'm not cultured
enough to know whether you you could be
a Colombian pretending I don't know I
know nothing about this continent you
have an ID to prove it all right I mean
you can be in this country I don't care
I'm not going to be like H this doesn't
look
legal this looks like it's been dragged
through a river on a
border I'm an immigrant as well isn't it
funny when I say that like I'm an
immigrant um okay so you you didn't even
wait CU there's rules usually I'm like
hey don't suggest food or animals cuz
they're easy to wrap up don't suggest
anything obvious or boring because it's
tedious be Crea and you were just like n
mate Mexicans just
like I the one thing I know about Mexico
is your flag cuz the the flag of my
country is terrible cuz it's the Union
Jack it's just like blue and red and
white the American flag's pretty [__]
cool cuz it's Stars and Stripes stuff
and then the Mexican flag is the green
white and red and then it's a cactus
with an eagle eating a snake which is
the most [__] metal Flag
Ever it's also terrifying and that's why
we should build a wall That's why cuz
they are
heathens you look at that flag that's
not a that's not the Canadian flag they
got a leaf a little leaf that's what
they are [__] [__] Mex [__]
flag like see we coming in to eat your
snakes Okay so one of the topics is
Mexicans and look if I I cuz I can't
contr why are you showing me cuz this is
Mexican beer as a Mexican you surely
cannot take pride in Corona beer this
is brood and bottle by Thia Modello
me
that's does that mean no better beer
what does that mean the best beer the
best beer that's lying isn't it lying
people as far as I'm aware my country
never invade in Mexico so this is
acceptable for me to say good
um okay that's that's topic number one
let's speed this up a bit and don't yeah
don't [__] start over there
are you that was an austral that was an
Australian accent wasn't it you're from
New Zealand okay um it's accept
it's while it may be acceptable let me
just say the New Zealand accent
especially saying the word acceptable is
so funny because they they can't say
their ease they say their ease is eyes
so could you say I slipped on the floor
I slipped on the
[Laughter]
floor it's [__] weird
okay tell you you were coming up with
col I'm just going to wrap out New
Zealand um and col whatever Mexicans no
more nationalities if anyone shouts out
Haitian okay wait so okay there's what
are you saying Afric South Africa what
is this why is this happening Chris rrap
about countries okay so do you want to
throw in any more we've got New Zealand
you did you just what did you say Indian
Indian you're not Indian
are are we you are [__] hell we can't
do this right South Africa New Zealand
Mexico and India does anyone want to say
a country that I can punch up at or
something yeah the Democratic Republic
of the Congo Chris there's not many
there there is not many no you shut the
[__] up now there's there's other this
is other people's tasks you're stealing
their jobs that's what's
happening some of you genuine like
that you know sometimes I post these
online I'm like this is be fun this I
would be
murdered except in England they would
make me a KN for this they like he's
going over there okay so what were you
shouting at the back
UK you well you did you say
Canada I'll take that
okay no I want a white
country sorry South Africa right
um I do not condone anything that is
about to come out my mouth if you don't
like it blame him for starting
this uh band I mean you you make the
music if you you do whatever you want
and I'll make the rap and it will be
[__] hell you're putting steel pan in
there red just to make it wrap about the
West Indies as well Chris you're at it
okay we've got New Zealand we've got
Canada Mexico India and they're here and
South Africa um and this is all your
fault this is all your
fault so upset okay genuinely I want to
put the microphone back in there and
[__] off I want to I want to blo all the
[__] out of this gig but let's do it
nice starting off freestyle like let's
go south the Border one chap saying
Mexico start it off sir you're out of
order he was like Chris rap about the
wall and the Border people coming
through smuggling in truck you know
these coyotes they getting it up the
cash I mean exploiting taking all the
cash extortion I'm so glad that you
asked say some stereotypes what they're
lazy now that's weird man it's [__]
crazy cuz lately I see Mexicans leaning
on the wall in my neighborhood outside
of the U-Haul you can hire them they'll
do the job for Less give them 20 bucks
they're like CES sir yes I only know the
one language and I go there he's like
Chris rhyme about Corona okay respect
you
Lina it's extra made by Modelo you know
they be owning the market over here ah
let's [__] start it get into you lady
was shouting India apologies yeah your
economy got thinner when we arrived you
used to be top of the charts used to be
so incredible oh my God but then the
British people they came and they
plundered it was horrible what they did
the scum there they're like oh yes we'll
cut through like butter let's do things
over here in Kolkata and Bombay not the
name anymore now it's Mumbai anyway on
the deli Shore I'd be pretty sure you be
coming back soon you'll drop a bomb on
Britain it will go boom and that will be
thoroughly deserved for what we did but
still trains entertaining kids is that
okay if we do that I'll WAP for you
Chris Tackle South Africa all right
[__] hell I cried let's talk about
aarth they separated the blacks from the
whites and maybe you two guys will be
like yeah that's right because you seem
to be stirring all of the [__] like rag
on the Indians just a little bit but no
it was a cause for alarm then Robert
mugabi came in like take back the farms
and all the other things oh it was
Bloody anyway over here yeah oh thank
you buddy that's my Canadian dude there
it's not painful he's like Chris flows
slow like Maple that's the syrup they
put it on their food pancakes mounes you
know they proved riding on the horse
grains in their hand the only country I
can dis New Zealand [__] these guys what
do you even do no one in here is aware
of you Wellington Oakland have you heard
it Christ Church no Chris we've not
deserved it anyway if you're over there
it's ever so weak all you're known for
is [__] sheep and other stuff there
we go the mic I won't drop it New
Zealand [__] you you [__]
Hobbit ATM ATM an automated T machine
correct no out oh okay we'll take five
suggestions then we'll we'll drop a beat
we'll uh do a wrap about it so um let's
kind of start on this side of the room
what would you guys like a wrap there's
a hand up there yes what would you like
a wrap exhausted exhausted the word
exhausted I like it thank you very much
unless that was just a very passive
aggressive heck
call Great exhausted and there's a hand
up here from the table of the person
with crutches right and so before we do
that may I ask how you came about your
your crutch incident first date it was a
first date you have to ask before you
get the kiss you have to
[__] get
away so what you were on a first date
ice skating you went ice skating you are
you thought you were so smooth I'm
so so what so what happened you just was
it I saved a couple of children you
saved a couple of
children so you were well on your way to
get at least a [__] on this
[Applause]
day you sacrificed your
yourself I mean yeah you expanding on
this is not going to be any more
impressive than what we're all thinking
in our
head well
done okay so you're on your table you
had a suggestion what was it your birth
J
jayen like jayen Hurtz yeah that means a
lot to
me uh I'm going to assume that's a
sports person right Jaylen Herz is a a
football player qu a quarterback okay
American football player an American
football player well yes I figured that
if it was a British football player
would have [__] known wouldn't
I also no one in Britain is called jayen
hurz that's not a name in our
country you called Jeremiah ouchie calm
down so Jaylen H is a quarterback for
your team for the Eagles so he he super
he yeah you know don't no don't remind
them um the other guy he was he the MVP
you said no he wasn't no the other guy
was okay so Jaylen Herz what what's
Jaylen Herz known for outside of
football being a beast being a
beast just outside of football as
well absolutely okay great he's just a
gentleman okay so were you on a date
with Jaylen Herz is
that it actually went really well Chris
I need these crutches because of how
hard he [__]
[Laughter]
me MVP for most violent penis
uh okay Jaylen hurs so the only thing I
know from the super was that it was the
first Super Ball to have two black
quarterbacks right or like first time in
a long time yeah okay cool first time
ever first time ever okay cool great
well that's that's he's a beast he was
in the and he squats
500 the [__] Jaylen Herz fan club is
here and there this is like the split
from Rome in the Catholic Church like
you're like £500 610 actually Chris no
we pray to the Pope in Road no we pray
to the Pope in
avenon okay jayen
great exhausted middle of the room um
yeah yes the lady or person I I said
lady cuz you're wearing white and then I
realize men can wear white as well ATM
what was it ATM ATM an automated T
machine correct no ask to M oh
[Applause]
okay I'm in Philly baby get it right I
wow I'm glad I knew that now cuz after
the show I was going to go and get some
cash out I go up to the nearest homeless
guy cuz they know where the cash
machines are goes excuse me do you know
where I can find ATM uh if you give me
$20 right
here I got you so as to mouth that's the
the sexual exploit of from anal
intercourse directly to the oral cavity
with no no grooming no cleansing in
between going day or nothing no no
nothing it's not true
as okay ATM exhausted jayen hurs okay
now this this this oh sorry I just tro
on your foot I do apologize um however
if it's on the stage then I am liable to
tread on it uh this this side over here
who's got a suggestion yeah feeding
Gizmo after dark feeding Gizmo after
dark that's a that's a Gremlins
reference for those you who don't know
um you're not allowed to get him wet
you're not all to feed him after dark
and and then this side of the room you
get the final suggestion yes oh my
friend in the Argentina shirt what would
you like a wrap
up [__] losers spot the losers in the
room it's surprising to see so many of
you sat next to women tonight you got
girlfriends well this is a rap based on
exhausted jayen Herz
ATM and feeding Gizmo after midnight and
Ru versus Neo let's uh let's do this
this is all made up get
[Music]
[Applause]
excited was two Stone don't know what it
is bro watching Gremlin late night goizo
my favorite fluffy guy get him from old
Chinatown the guy with the beard
mustache drooping down is like care
you've got to do it right don't get him
damp soy never feed him after midnight
like the opposite of Cinderella coach to
a pumpkin you feed him something Gremlin
start jumping emerging from deep in his
paws they're green horrible things ring
called up with the claws they start
coming after you invading the town
you're like Gizmo his fur white and
brown that's the Harper color of the
hukin Street Fighter yeah play to new
but this one a real beat them up if
you've never watched this Chun keeps it
up the dick I mean she's attractive for
an animated go but Ru going into the
Matrix the world in 1999 controlled by
the squid robots an agent Smith he's
like yo lots of people underground who's
this morus says Neo use this the spoon
there is no spoon but who comes through
hukin hukin yes that's rayu he bursts in
and of course Neo's there who's here
Luke Skywalker with the force cuz you're
nerds I knew that you'd like that later
he starts fighting a green lightsaber
and so it's Street Fighter Neo and a guy
with the sword it's like a little
triangle one of them gored through the
middle and Neo he Dodges he Minds
bending backwards with the bullet time I
can't do it properly but here we go
again I'm exhausted man rapping to the
children of the'80s playing games on
their SNES or on their Sega Mega Drive
what is this I'm so knackered I'm really
cream crackered take a little break
pause while this rapper talks about
exhaustion maybe have a nap but not
right now cuz we do the freestyle rap
coming over here you know what makes the
[__] squir a 610 spatting guy called
Jay and hurt the ladies will love him
the guys do too but there's a
disagreement between you two
£500 that's a fact 610 he's got a super
strong back he can squat cute glutes but
can't win the ring still he's the MVP of
entering anybody you know whereabouts
starting at the back door then he says
ass to mouth and of course if he ask you
say yes I want to do that oral and anal
Ingress why do I motion on this just
flip them round yeah spin it a bit from
the bum to the Yum the bum to the Yum
the bum yum bum yum yum it's fun yeah
You' got to be careful don't get it
wrong why use a bday just use a tongue
start scraping off it offends you don't
worry it's a clean bum had an enema made
sure it's breaked out that's what it do
and what's this Neo but [__] rayu
there we go the ATM when he shooting and
when rayu comes he shouts
haduken on the S of gay Australians
gentleman here what
[Laughter]
[Applause]
is May I inquire it's your name uh
Javier Javier oh my God you are the the
least gay man
here you just impregnated the entire
front
row like it's not even my period have
yeah
[__] yeah you get pregnant on your
period Chris that's how it
works so uh what um what what country
did you you born in uh Mexico Mexico
[__] yeah which bit uh Mexico City
Mexico City holy [__] that's you were
shocked just there you were just there
but now you're here so you could [__]
he
[Applause]
instead pretty
cool pretty cool I mean it's it's not
you know out of all of me it's it's one
of the biggest cities in the world I
think it's like the third biggest city
in the world used to be the biggest but
then he got ever taken by China which
you know
um you know I think Mexicans started Co
to kill off Chinese people so they could
get their status back with the biggest
sa that's just me that's just little
opinion I spread on
Reddit so ja Javier who is a human
embodiment of a Hawaiian cocktail
what it's just like you know cuz the
shirt screams pineapple and the hair
screams
[Laughter]
pineapple now yeah if we were in Miami I
I would assume drug Smuggler but what do
you what do you do I'm I'm an I'm an
influencer you're a an influencer an
influencer of course well you've
influenced these ladies vaginas to
become very
modest that's pretty cool what um how
many may I ask how many followers you
have uh 10 million 10 10 million on Tik
Tok that's pretty
[__] that's pretty impressive I
imagine I don't know I'm not on it
because I'm over 30 and not a sexual
predator
you're allowed on it cuz you're making
the content everyone else get [__]
up you're not under 21 you shouldn't be
on there so I mean when you were grown
up jaier I mean what type what type of
content do you make I do movie and TV
show reviews movie and TV show reviews
of Spanish shows specifically uh no a
little bit of everything but I do it in
Spanish in Spanish cool yeah I mean
there that's the third biggest language
in the world isn't it yeah English is
still bigger
um
but the thing is I feel like having
maybe maybe you are similar to me and
that you were like ah the English Market
is flooded I'll do it in Spanish and you
appe that in the same way that in the UK
I'm terribly unfunny and then I came
over
here our audiences will just laugh at
anything a British man says he's so
smart so you do the movie reviews when
you were little Javier cuz you you're
what in your mid-20s I'm 29 29 oh that's
pretty the facial hair
it suits you actually um what when you
were little influencing wasn't a thing
Tik Tok wasn't a thing what did you want
to be when you were little um I wanted
to do something with movies something
with movies I act direct maybe review
them now now you review them you cut out
the middleman you just
like [__] the D it's hard to make a
movie isn't
it I could just sit
there go three stars and get [__]
rich
what's your what's your favorite movie
of of of the last year um I really loved
everything everywhere all at once
everything everywhere all at once made
by the Daniels which uh I I I saw it on
a plane which I don't think is really
the the way men experience it you saw on
a plane too holy
[__] it's great I mean I feel like we
have a spiritual connection it's like a
triangle between you me
and
may may I inquire it's your name Madam
Jada Jada yes love you to meet you Jada
and J you from New York San Francisco
San Francisco you said that with a
disdain for this city which I do not
feel that anyone from San Francisco is
allowed to have um like e New York have
you looked at your city have you looked
at it um I like it it's pretty cool uh
Jada what do you
do HR oh how many people have you fired
this
month why are you gesturing to
him I mean with shorts that short you
must have violated some sort
[Applause]
of what um what what industry are you
in fintech oh Financial technology for
anyone who doesn't speak San
Francisco you there like she works with
dolphins what
fintech HR J from San Francisco when you
were a little girl J what did you want
to
be a princess a princess oh lovely stuff
lovely stuff which uh which princess cuz
I mean back when you were a little girl
Princess Tiana didn't exist there wasn't
a black aerial so who are
you there wasn't there wasn't now now
there's Role Models but back then po
pocah hunas was the closest that is so
shame on you shame on you Walt Disney
but a young black girl in San Francisco
had to be like well she's brownish I
guess but uh [__] John Smith could
get it couldn't he he was oh yeah just
ignore the fact that technically she was
14 in the movie um it was a different
time wasn't it uh
what what was your have you seen pocah
Hunter have you uh yeah yeah what was
your review of pocah
Hunter unrealistic
uh you know when John Smith and
Pocahontas lie down on that blanket she
would have caught small pox wouldn't she
she
would how do you how do you say paint
with all the colors of the wind in
Spanish how do you say paint with all
the colors of the wind in
Spanish paint paint the the main song
from pop
oh I feel like you didn't review it you
watched it when you were a child I
watched it a long time you watched it a
long time ago Okay cool so we've got
we've got Jada who works in fintech in
HR and wanted to be a princess San
Francisco we have harier who's from
Mexico City who is an influencer on Tik
Tok with 10 million followers who who
loves loves reviewing movies and did
want to be in movies but then decided
why bother with
effort and he looks like a p
colada well that's good um so Gina do me
a favor let's uh let's let's hit this
cuz growing up I I wanted to be a rapper
that was my dream and we'll we'll find
out whether I pursued it we'll find out
whether I achieved it but this is a
little freestyle for for Jada and Javier
both names and begin with Jay you
thought you trick me out with that
little silent one but no um and this is
going to be pretty [__] exciting so
for you guys and for the rest of you
let's uh let's do this
cool a picture a beautiful man hairy
than anyone you've seen front row area
his name is Javier where's he coming
from so pretty fic Dy from Mexico City
like 35 people over there South of the
Border and they see him like where
you're so famous who followers LST like
CC we see you on Tik Tok What 10 million
for a silly man there I'm not being mean
I really do care you sat in the movie
like I'm mean I'll judge this [__] what
I see on the screen
robero old as [__] alino old as [__] I
want to watch something that's like a
party you prefer Margo Robie in the bar
maybe maybe you were spinning it back
Christopher Nolan like Translating that
in Spanish what does he even say does he
translate the bag ofad to that way I
have become death destroyer of girls
worlds wait you're the guy destroyer of
girls because the girls so beautiful
that's a little mind you wanted to make
the movies but you're like I'm [__] with
camera work directing and acting and so
I'll just do there sit backing and
passing my judgment like a film reviewer
that's so brilliant people see right
through you and how long are your
reviews surely it's like 15 seconds or
maybe 22 people go thumbs up or thumbs
down you were looking everywhere for a
princess who was brown and you found her
nearest one there haunters while she's
got the long hair and is black and that
matches so you thought yeah I'll throw
my ball in her court and walk around
this forest with my little friendly
raccoon I hope some European settlers
come soon I take with all the colors of
the wind the other one you could have
thrown yourself in was moland cuz she's
at least not white that's literally the
two ones that you had in the fight Walt
Disney we can all say this he hated
people of color he's so racist he was
saying no the princesses have to be
white he would turn in his grave he
would get such a fright if he saw the
little mermaid what did you think about
that one with the girl swimming there in
the drink did you like it he's like yeah
one thumb up not two but that's okay got
fun discuss you're in San Francisco the
worst city by far working in fintech in
HR that's such a great job really
admiring basically you're like yes I do
the firing you sir you're fired yes it's
your fault cuz you committed a grievous
sexual assault your shorts were very
skimpy up there we can see your thighs
with your lovely body hair walking in
the office look at my limbs no the only
Tech we deal in here is fins like
dolphins or sharks or Wales free Willie
that would be a free Willie cuz the
shorts so silly well there we go a flame
rat we can persuade you so give it up
for Javier and give it up for
Jada
w